Це сталося рівно два роки тому.
Незадовго до нападу на концертний зал "Батаклан"
терористи розстріляли з автоматів ресторани
поруч із цим квітковим магазином.
П'ятеро людей загинули та багатьох поранило.
Власник крамниці на ім’я Кадер, алжирець за походженням,
не постраждав, але лише дивом.
Того дня він закрив магазин на кілька хвилин раніше, ніж зазвичай.
Через два дні знову спалахнула паніка.
Здалося, що відбувається інший теракт.
Люди сховалися у квітковому магазині.
Кадер та його брат Аісса надали притулок своїм сусідам.
"У нас дуже багато поліції,
ми тут у безпеці, боятися не треба".
Це виявилось хибною тривогою.
Але двоє братів не змогли впоратися із наслідками.
В Аісси розвинувся рак і він помер навесні цього року.
А Кадер страждає від нападів тривоги
і часто відчуває себе виснаженим.
"Біля цього дерева загинуло двоє людей:
чоловік з Алжиру та молода американська жінка.
Їй було лише 20 чи 22 роки".
Кадер каже, що в нього психологічна травма від терактів.
Сотні парижан почуваються так само.
Але держава надавала допомогу лише людям,
яким безпосередньо загрожували терористи.
Директор компенсаційного фонду визнає:
не всім жертвам надається відповідна допомога.
"Ми не були готові до таких жорстоких терактів.
Це величезний виклик для держави.
Компенсаційний фонд не мав можливості
застрахувати таку велику кількість потерпілих,
і формальності, ймовірно, були занадто складними".
Занадто складними та бюрократичними ...
За словами психологині Керол Даміані,
жертвам терактів слід негайно надавати психологічну підтримку.
"Психологічну травму отримують не лише безпосередньо постраждалі,
а й ті, хто потрапляє на місце події вже після небезпеки.
Наприклад, рятувальники.
І що швидше люди отримують психологічну допомогу,
то кращі їхні шанси на подолання травми".
Кадер та його сусіди
все ще страждають від почуття тривоги.
"З часом стає лише гірше.
Я ніколи не був у психолога,
але думаю, що мені справді потрібна допомога".
Більшість парижан намагаються продовжувати жити як раніше,
але чи це можливо?
Багато з них були б вдячні за більшу підтримку з боку держави.